it feels very surreal to be honest this
is what dreams are made of because the
originalism acquire cast is officially
back together Halle Todd Robert
Carradine and Jake Thomas are set to
reprise their roles as Joe Sam and Matt
McGuire in the Disney Plus revival this
will be the first time in 15 years since
the core cast has reunited but can we
also expect to see Gordo and Miranda I
mean I think the chances are high
I can't tell too much but I think people
are going to be very surprised before
Disney Plus announced the reboot in
August hilary hinted to ET in 2018 that
there had been talks about bringing
lizzie mcguire back for quite some time
what's happening is that a guy can't no
no it's definitely not a good I want to
like get everyone okay while talking
about it but um yeah I mean I love her
so much and I think that she was so
important to girls at an important time
in their life and if she could be
important to them again at this age like
I think that would be amazing
so the question is what do we know about
the new and improved Lizzie McGuire fun
because I clearly am a mom and we have
so many similarities but our lives are
very different so she's been living in
New York and I'm not sure how long she's
gonna stay there but that's gonna be
like all a part of the journey along
with balancing motherhood raising her
two kids Luca and banks Hillary also
stars on TV land's younger which was
just renewed for a seventh season I
think it's gonna be a little challenging
you know like mom is my number one rule
in life and so I'm a little worried but
you know we're gonna we're gonna make it
all happen I think that Lizzy's gonna
shoot here and then I'm gonna go to New
York and shoot shoot and a season of
younger and then like I don't know I
just keep keep juggling it you know
[Music]